I've always wanted to
drive across the country.
I just never thought I
quit my job to do it.
Let me back up
as long as I can remember,
I wanted to make films,
tell stories,
but having traditional parents
that wasn't safe for them.
You know the meme that goes, Hey dad, I
want to be an actor, and he says, son,
it's pronounced doctor.
That was my life.
So I took the traditional route and
studied computer science on the side.
I made films,
tried to make a difference,
but ultimately I took the job that every
parent can brag about at dinner parties
coming out of college, I took a job
thinking I would change the world, help.
I thought I was the
change at the beginning.
I made the most of every day
and it was novel and exciting.
I was working with interesting people
and I made it my mission to learn
something new. Every day I had a spark,
learn, innovate, fail, repeat,
creepy.
But over time
things started to change.
The novelty was gone
and my life became routine.
I drank the same coffee,
made the same calls,
took the same route to work
each day was a copy of itself.
One day while I was working,
I came across this design website
and had a list of rules, life rules.
I started reading them.
Rule number two 33 never fucking so
well.
Number one 68 make a fucking difference.
Ooh,
we're on number two oh five
get in over your fucking head.
Rule number 58
is your fucking hang out.
Okay.
Those rules that could back to
me every day since I read them
my whole life,
I tried to live by those rules.
I had broken every fucking one.
When I first started working, I thought
it was going to make a difference.
Okay?
And now I realized I was
just another employee,
nothing number.
I didn't want to wake up at the end of
my career realizing that all they did was
survive.
Just another drop in the bucket who
went along to pay off his mortgage is
student debt.
So I finally did it.
I pack my stuff,
closed out my projects and gave my notice.
I quit.
Trust me.
It's much easier said than done.
Okay?
Honestly,
I'm not looking to be happy.
Some days I'm miserable in aching.
I'm interested in,
and that's where the living room,
right
as I drive across the country, I'm going
to places far outside my comfort zone.
Places I've never heard
of. Small towns, people,
they're countless stories,
landscapes I never knew existed.
Sunrises and sunsets.
I sleep in the car on
the road in $20 motels.
Breathing air is so fresh.
It makes my heart race
at times. It's grueling and
I love every moment of it.
I've always wanted to tell stories
about real people that changed lives,
and I'm going to do just that.
My name is Tamra Chavon and I'm out to
tell the stories of those who are finding
their own way. The ones who, who've
swam upstream for what they believe in,
the ones who left the life of
safety for something greater.
The ones who were cast aside only to
make their own path, the innovators,
the trendsetters,
some might call them the crazy.